it's been announced by Buckingham Palace
that Prince Philip the Duke of Edinburgh
has been taken to hospital and we can go
now to our correspondent Rhiannon Mills
for more Rhiannon what do we know very
short statement that's just been
released by Buckingham Palace I will
read that to you in full now it says the
Duke of Edinburgh travelled from Norfolk
this morning to the King Edward the
seventh Hospital in London for
observation and treatment in relation to
a pre-existing condition the admission
is a precautionary measure on the advice
of his Royal Highnesses doctor now it's
worth reminding ourselves that Prince
Philip is 98 years old he's been
spending a great deal of time recently
in Norfolk staying at wood farm enjoying
retirement it was in 2017 that he
announced that he was stepping back from
public duties of course over the years
people have talked a great deal about
his illnesses we know that back in 2012
during the time of the Queen's Diamond
Jubilee pageant he was admitted to
hospital then with a bladder infection
in 2013 he had abdominal surgery he also
in 2011 suffered from chest pains of
course within this statement the palace
at the moment are not going into any
details about what exactly he's being
treated for in hospital at the moment
they're simply saying this is a
pre-existing condition he was also in
2017 admitted to hospital again at the
time people talked about him suffering
from a pre-existing condition and at the
time many people were talking about
whether or not not that was related to
the bladder infection that we've seen
that had flared up over a number of
different occasions over a number of
different years the last time that we
saw the Duke of Edinburgh with his
family was earlier this year back in May
when he attended the wedding of lady
Gabriella
Windsor he looked very sprightly he
looked very well he was seen laughing in
joking with Prince Harry he seemed to be
in very fine form but of course at 98
years old it is inevitable that there
will always be speculation about his
health especially as back in 2017 it was
then he made that announcement that he
was going to step back from public life
that he was stepping back from public
duties I think he is a man who are very
proud man who did not want to grow any
older in public but just to reconfirm
this statement that we've heard from
Buckingham Palace just in the last few
moments also talking about how the Duke
of Edinburgh has traveled from Norfolk
this morning to the King Edward the
seventh Hospital in London for
observation and treatment in relation to
a pre-existing condition they go on to
say the advice is the admission is a
precautionary measure on the advice of
his Royal Highnesses doctor it's also
worth adding that only this morning the
Queen travelled from Buckingham Palace
up to Norfolk recently we've seen
pictures of her getting off the train in
King's Lynn so in some ways that may
show that the palace sir maybe not
panicking about this the fact that he's
been taken here to London but the Queen
at the moment is currently in
Sandringham not with her husband